john f kennedy and bobby kennedy are the
subjects of david talbot's new book
brothers he looks at the political and
personal relationship between the
president and his attorney general from
the book passage bookstore in san
francisco this is an hour
good evening and welcome to book passage
your small but feisty independent
bookstore
with what we think is the best view in
the city
uh
tonight's guest is david talbot who's
come to tell us about
brothers the hidden history of the
kennedy years
david talbot was born and raised in
los angeles
he has been a lifelong activist and
provocateur
going way back to days at harvard
preparatory school in southern
california and also uh uc santa cruz
he comes by this activism quite
naturally since his father
was lyle talbot the movie and television
actor
and left-wing labor activist
who co-founded the screen actors guild
uh
[Music]
after uc santa cruz mr talbot wrote
in 1978
creative differences profiles of
hollywood dissidents
and in 1989
burning desires sex and america a report
from the field
after that he was a senior editor at
mother jones magazine for five years
and after that he was an editor at the
examiner's image magazine
from 1985 to 1994
when
the examiner was still a newspaper
and not the sorry
publication that it is today
in 1995
he founded salon.com and was
editor-in-chief and ceo at salon.com for
10 years he is now chairman of the board
please welcome david talbott
[Applause]
thank you very much for that
introduction it sounded like my fbi
filed points
[Laughter]
well i i had some prepared remarks
tonight but
i'm going to put them aside and just
read to you uh
vincent bullios's entire 1600 page book
and answer it point by point
if you'll just bear with me for the next
several weeks
no but seriously
uh
i would like to
i would like to begin with just a few
remarks
and then uh
to impose on you by reading a bit from
the book if i could and then
uh answering any questions you might
have and then just going out and
enjoying this evening before it's it's
gone this beautiful night all of you
staring dreamily past me
well they say uh history is a
never-ending argument and if that's the
case
my book brothers
makes two
main arguments i believe
one is that bobby kennedy was the
country's first assassination conspiracy
theorist
and number two and this is turning out
to be the most controversial aspect of
my book uh
from the at least some of the early
reviews is that the kennedys were heroes
and they were they were heroes for the
simple reason that they kept us out of
war
as i say this has become controversial
because in the last 20 years or more
we've been going through a revisionist
interpretation of the kennedy presidency
it didn't start with seymour hirsch's
dark side of camelot but of course that
best-selling book
definitely
was part of this backlash against the
kennedys
that book portrayed president kennedy as
a decadent prince
reckless someone who put the country at
risk
we now have a journalist as prominent
chris hitchens who dismissively refer to
jfk as a vulgar hoodlum
and even in academia the
picture of jfk as a cold war militant
has taken firmly uh hold
but i hope my book is a part of a third
wave of scholarship that challenges
this revisionist look at jfk
my book concentrates on the tumultuous
inner life of the kennedy presidency
it was a presidency that i think was a
government at war with itself
i call it rome on the potomac
an era of sinister menace hung over the
kennedy presidency as jfk i believe
tried to lead the country out of the
cold war before his time
this provoked a sharp backlash from very
powerful forces in the u.s
we know remember remember president
eisenhower's famous uh farewell address
to the nation which he warned us of the
encroaching power of the military
industrial complex
kennedy soon found out how powerful
these forces were at the bay of pigs
which was the first
great crisis in his administration the
failed invasion of cuba
that the cia had orchestrated and told
him in to use language from today's cia
world it was a slam dunk
it turned out not to be of course it was
a disaster
and kennedy later feeling sandbagged by
the cia and furious that the
intelligence they'd given him
vowed to
shatter the cia into a thousand pieces
and scatter it to the winds
the national security establishment was
equally enraged at kennedy
i think my if if my book does one thing
i hope it it creates a sense of what the
kennedys were up against because most
books don't evoke this kind of poisonous
atmosphere that prevailed in washington
in those years when you read the oral
histories and or do interviews with
people who are still alive from this
world the intelligence world the
military world
you get a sense of the of the vitriol
the hatred that they had for the
kennedys
curtis lemay the notorious head of the
air force
referred to them as cockroaches who
should have been crushed
jfk in return thought lemay was a madman
lemay of course thought you could
actually fight and win a nuclear war and
he was determined to do this while the
united states had nuclear superiority in
the early 60s
at one point he stunned a dinner mate at
a georgetown dinner party turning to
this woman who happened to be the wife
of a u.s senator and saying we're going
to have a nuclear war with the soviet
union before the end of the year
and if you want you and your children
and grandchildren to survive you should
take them out west to tumbleweed country
and that was her only chance of
surviving
john kennedy was a very different man he
was determined he he knew what the
nuclear stakes were and he was
determined to keep the country from
falling into that precipice
in his famous speech at american
university in june 1963 i think we see
the visionary
kennedy at his best a speech written for
him by theodore sorensen his eloquent
speechwriter
and we can't even imagine a leader today
using these words and at the height of
the cold war imagine the the
revolutionary message of this speech in
which he says we must empathize with our
enemy no matter how repellent
the value systems uh of governments that
we oppose the soviet system communist
system
we are all people and we and and and
he ends with this we all inhabit the
same small planet we all breathe the
same air we all cherish our children's
future
and we are all mortal
the national security elite just didn't
know what to do with a man like this
they were concerned about his private
life they thought
they were snooping on his private life
one affair that i go into in particular
which unnerved them was his relationship
with a woman named mary meyer
who had the divorced wife of a former ci
official named kordmeyer they had known
each other since they were in prep
school and they began a very i believe
serious relationship uh while jack was
in the white house
they uh mary meyer was a pre-hippie
hippie a bohemian spirit a woman who was
determined to turn on the washington
power structure using the powers of lsd
and her own i think charms
i think once the cia found out about
this relationship which they did it was
just one more
uh
one more
a cloud hanging over this presidency
i think what they thought of jack
kennedy essentially was this that he was
a morally compromised
physically uh debilitated and
intellectually dangerous president
the the atmosphere the the mutinous
atmosphere in washington became so
severe that at one point
kennedy who frequently referred to the
possibility of his presidency ending
violently somehow in a coup or
assassination and i think he probably
did this more than any other president i
can think of in american history with
the possible exception of abraham
lincoln
but at one point he goes to friends in
hollywood and implores them to make a
film version of the book seven days in
may which was a bestseller by fletcher
nebel about a political about a military
coup that comes close to toppling a
presidency
neville had been
inspired to write this after
interviewing curtis lemay and hearing
the kind of talk
about jfk that he was prone
prone to
uh
the pressures on kennedy were constant
to go to war in berlin and laos and
vietnam but above all in cuba cuba could
very uh
could very well have become the iraq of
its day
in fact there's a fascinating national
intelligence estimate produced by cia
analysts
about uh
such a scenario that was produced in
1962 that i came across and it eerily
reads just like iraq today what it says
is
if the unit the united states was to
invade not like the bay of pigs but an
all-out military invasion we would
quickly sweep aside castro's forces and
march onto havana
triumphantly but we'd soon become bogged
down in a lengthy occupation of the
island there would be terrorist attacks
on our troops our troops would respond
over respond civilians would be killed
the civilian population would turn
against us we become increasingly
isolated within the world because of our
unilateral military action
it sounds very familiar well i think
john kennedy was no george w bush he
realized that was a possibility a
distinct possibility he realized what
the stakes were he was determined not to
get bogged down militarily like that in
cuba and he was determined to prevent
the nuclear holocaust which was a
distinct possibility throughout his
administration
the kennedys were constantly trying to
stay on top of this world the shadowy
world the cia's secret war on castro
and it was this particular
world that bobby kennedy cast his
suspicions immediately on the afternoon
of november 22nd
he knew that the cia in the mafia
this kind of frankenstein monster
had already come together in a dark
alliance to kill castro he thought he'd
stop that
but that alliance had continued and we
know from his conversations that day
exactly where he was looking he was
looking at the cia the mafia and the
cuban exile community
it was a very dramatic moment in
american history
at one point aids come to him that
afternoon say he has to surround his
house in virginia with security with
federal marshals because they don't
trust the fbi or the secret service at
that point because they think who's ever
killed president kennedy is coming for
bobby kennedy next
despite
the dangers that always existed for
bobby kennedy from that moment on
until his own death in 1968 he was
determined from that moment on
to
find out who the killers of his brother
were and to reopen the case
he struggled with great grief and
depression the sense of guilt that he
should have prevented the assassination
of his brother
but after initial burst of energy and
sinking into a deep depression
he struggles out of this and he comes
back to political life because he knows
the only way that he can find justice
for his brother is to reclaim the white
house that the candidates have lost
he runs for senate
from new york in 1964 and then for the
presidency in 1968 an enormous act of
courage
not only is he challenging a sitting
president over a war that was started
or at least escalated under his brother
but he knows that he's taking his life
in his hands he knows that whoever has
killed his brother those forces are
still very much
alert
and threatened by bobby's campaign
but he's deeply
moved
by the the wounds that the country is
suffering civil rights vietnam war this
endless war like we have today the
country had turned against the war the
public but the government seemed
determined to plot on
i came across this amazing speech that
bobby gave in sacramento a shopping mall
where he was surrounded as usual by
these clutching
swarms of people it was
more religious experience than a
political experience his campaign he'd
be clawed at he'd be bleeding and
scratched at the end of it
but i i when i hear these words i think
of our country today and and
and the people who are dying and
suffering in iraq what bobby said that
day in sacramento was with was this
which of these brave young men dying in
the rice paddies of vietnam might have
written the symphony
which of them might have cured cancer or
played in the world series
which of them might have built a bridge
or taught a small child to read
it's ours our responsibility
to let these men live
that's the kind of i think message that
american leaders need to deliver today
and just as boldly as bobby did
after bobby was killed
the band of brothers as he called them
the men
who had served the kennedy brothers so
loyally
and a number of whom he had called on to
help him investigate secretly his
brother's murder
began to drift away their heart was cut
from them at this point
they weren't able to pursue
take up bobby's mission and pursue the
case either his own assassination or
jfk's
and if i could i'd like to read you a
fairly brief section from the book about
one of these men
particularly poignant story kenny
o'donnell who some of you know that name
who was a
candy loyalist from the early days in
boston and then became chief of staff in
in the kennedy white house
so if you'll just bear with me i'll read
that passage
with my glasses
enjoy the view here for a minute
so this takes place uh after the deaths
of both kennedy's
well begins before the death of bobby
and you'll see
where it goes from there kenny o'donnell
and his fellow
irish mafia warhorse dave powers were
eyewitnesses to history on november 22nd
1963.
riding immediately behind the
president's limousine in the secret
service backup car
the two men saw it all that day
before the motorcade began jfk attentive
as always to political details had asked
them to take seats in the follow-up car
so they could closely observe the
reactions to him and jackie from the
crowds
the two men could never
forget
what they saw that afternoon
as the shots rang out powers blurred
kenny i think the president's been shot
o'donnell quickly made a sign of the
cross
as both men stared intently at the man
they had loved and served ever since he
was a scrawny young congressional
candidate a final shot took the side of
his head off
o'donnell would later recall
we saw pieces of bone and brain tissue
and bits of his reddish hair flying
through the air the impact lifted him
and shook him limply as if he was a rag
doll and then he dropped out of our
sight sprawled across the back seat of
the car i said to dave he's dead
o'donnell empowers both world war ii
veterans distinctly heard at least two
shots come from the grassy knoll area in
front of the motorcade but when they
later told us to the fbi they were
informed that they must be wrong
if they did if they did not change their
story it was impressed on the men it
could be very damaging to the country
so o'donnell did alter his account to
fit the official version
testifying before the warrant commission
that the shots had come from the right
rear the direction of the school book
depository powers however could not be
fully shaken from his story even though
one of the warren commission employees
who took his statement kept interrupting
him powers insisted that he had the
impression that the noise
appeared to come from the front as well
as from behind
which is probably why dave powers was
never invited to testify before the
warren commission as the more amenable
o'donnell was
five years after the assassination
o'donnell confessed to his friend boston
congressman and future speaker of the
house tip o'neill what he had dutifully
hidden from the public
he had heard two shots from the fence on
the grassy knoll
o'neal who was dining with
o'donnell and a few other people at
jimmy's harborside restaurant in in
boston was stunned that's not what you
told the warren commission he said
you're right replied o'donnell i told
the fbi what i had heard but they said
it couldn't have happened that way and
that i must have been imagining things
so i testified the way they wanted me to
i just went didn't want to stir up any
more pain and trouble for the family
i can't believe that said o'neill i
wouldn't have done that in a million
years i would have told the truth tips
you have to understand said o'donnell
the family everybody wanted this thing
behind them
it's clear from o'neill's account and
one given by dave powers who suggested
that hoover himself pressured odile to
change his account that the fbi played a
key role in this fateful decision
and this fateful distortion of the
record but it's equally obvious that
o'donnell was also responding to signals
from the kennedy family and that could
only mean his close friend bobby the man
whom his life and career had completely
been completely intertwined with
ever since they were harvard roommates
the intensely loyal o'donnell who was as
close as a brother to bobby would never
have changed his story without first
checking with kennedy and bobby had made
it clear that he was not ready to
publicly question the official story
about the assassination
whatever his reasons for hiding the
truth about dallas o'donnell's decision
weighed heavily on him
the kennedys had been his life
tough taciturn utterly dedicated he had
put in slavish hours at the white house
but he laughed at the notion was a
sacrifice tough job my ass it was the
best job i ever had he would say
but now the man he had served was gone
he wished the bullets that hit him
instead he told his wife
and instead of helping bring the
president's killers to justice he was
misleading the country the assassination
was the end of his life his son kenny jr
told me he never was the same again none
of the men around kennedy were but
especially him
o'donnell confided what he really
witnessed in dealey plaza to his son as
well
he said there was fire from two
different directions recalled the
younger o'donnell and his father would
bitterly complain about his experience
with the warring commission i'll tell
you this right now he told them they
didn't want to know
o'donnell called the inc inquiry the
most pointless investigation i've ever
seen
pulling out the records of his testimony
to show kenny junior he would point to a
passage with disgust and say look this
is ridiculous they weren't even looking
for an answer to this
o'donnell might also have been disgusted
with his own performance before the
commission
in the months after dallas o'donnell
would devote himself to helping jackie
the two had clung to each other like old
soldiers ever since the assassination
as they flew back to washington that day
both were stained with jack's blood
kenny and bobby found solace by
gathering friends at jackie's georgetown
house and entertaining her with old
stories about jack
but o'donnell could not put dallas
behind him what he and dave powers
witnessed that day continued to work
inside them
o'donnell experienced wrenching bouts of
nausea for six months after dallas
powers began suffering violent headaches
the pain was focused in the same part of
his skull where he had seen the bullet
blow off the top of his friend's head
he couldn't get the quote sickening
sound out of his own head like a
grapefruit splattering against the side
of a wall
o'donnell began drinking heavily
when friends warned him to go easy on
the stuff the man nicknamed the cobra
would fix them with a cold glare and
tell them go to hell and mind your own
business
but he listened when jackie and bobby
sat him down and talked to him
it worked observed his daughter hell and
he seemed to step forward into human
company again
but kenny o'donnell never fully
recovered he just lived the rest of his
life with a heavy heart said his son
he ran twice for the democratic
nomination for governor in massachusetts
but his political talent was as a behind
the scenes man not as a campaigner and
he lost both times
bobby's assassination was the final blow
kenny jr was with his father the night
he heard his father just spoken to rfk
on the phone about the california
primary results
it's over his father told him after
hearing that history had repeated itself
that's all he said we called kenny jr
that was the absolute end
when o'donnell died in a boston hospital
in september 1977 at age 53
his family requested that the cause of
death be withheld
but the press reported he had succumbed
to a liver ailment
there was no more bobby to tell him to
put down the bottle
his memorial service was held at st
matthews cathedral where he had escorted
jack's casket 14 years before walking
slowly up connecticut avenue from the
white house
at the irish wake held afterwards at the
mayflower hotel a boston politician
reminisced about his fallen friend
without the candidate he said
o'donnell was the music without the harp
thanks
[Applause]
i just want to leave you with this
because again this is the part of the
book that i'm being challenged by some
historians about but i feel uh you know
very deeply about it and
there was a a moment when i was
interviewing ted sorents and the
eloquent speechwriter who who really
lifted i think the rhetoric and and the
the vision of the kennedy presidency so
high
and sorensen's still living and still
deeply pain to talk about those days
with uh intrusive journalists like
myself
but at one point he's wrestling with
this idea he said i i know that jack
kennedy dead
lived for a purpose i just can't believe
he died for a purpose
he said it would give me great
consolation if i knew this
dear friend of 11 years this man i
served so closely
had gone to dallas knowing what the
stakes were knowing that he was
confronting these dark forces
and that they
killed him for what he believed in what
he was trying to do with the nation
um
the truth is i think ted in his heart
does know that's the case
because after bobby died he delivered a
beautiful eulogy for bobby kennedy uh at
the law firm where he works still to
this day in new york
and he was he was challenging this idea
that it was already taking hold in the
media that the kennedys were cursed
and he said there is no curse upon the
kennedys they have met their share of
ill fate because they had more than
their share of courage and the
conviction required to try and tempt
fate
they died heroic deaths because they
lived heroic lives
and if there's one thing i would like my
book to accomplish it's it's conveying
that sense of the kennedy presidency
thank you very much
[Applause]
yes
[Applause]
is that the case
yes
i mean
what what i really wanted to do was
create an emotional narrative around the
kennedy story
uh you know
it's um particularly the assassination
is such a dark labyrinth and so many
researchers have gotten lost it's a
rabbit hole one friend of mine who
actually has written about it anthony
summers warned me before i did this book
but um i i think by following bobby
kennedy's light into this dark tunnel
it's enormously revealing because he was
the attorney general of the united
states he did know more about the dark
forces in american politics than i think
any public figure of his day and of
course because of his love for his
brother he was utterly committed to
getting at the truth
the truth is i think bobby was on the
right path and when he was the phone
calls he made that day basically i think
now uh a consensus has developed around
those suspicions among the most
intelligent assassination researchers
including by the way the church
committee in the 1970s which people
forget and the house select committee on
assassinations both of those committees
and the best investigators for those
committees were looking at the same area
they thought something very dark had
happened within the cia's secret war on
castro and those guns had been turned
against kennedy instead
uh so yes i do hope the book creates uh
you know you're not supposed to say
oliver stone because he's been so
pilloried and
you know stigmatized but at least that
film created enormous public uh uproar
and forced the government to release
thousands of documents a law was passed
in 1992 called the jfk records
collection act many of the documents
that i used as a researcher were as a
result of that but the cia continues to
sit on thousands of documents that are
very relevant and a good friend of mine
jeff morley again is going to court this
summer to try to compel the ci to
release these documents he's a reporter
with the washington post and i think is
the
really the reigning expert on this
mentioned dorothy kilgallen in your book
yes uh is there anything other than what
you wrote in your book about her because
i i find that so intriguing
um you know that whole situation and how
she suddenly died of an overdose of a
drug that hadn't been prescribed in her
that's right well it is it's one of the
one more bizarre footnote in the whole
kennedy story dorothy kilgallon for
those of you too young to remember
i remember on what's my line but she was
a gossip columnist who worked for the
hearst newspapers
and she at one point scored
really the uh you know the scoop of her
career which was an exclusive interview
with jack ruby a jailhouse interview
and she was a very good crime reporter
actually she had a background in that
sort of tabloid you know
uh you know crime reporter and she came
back telling friends that she was going
to break the kennedy case based on this
interview with ruby you know bobby
kennedy thought ruby was also a very a
key to understanding the crime because
within 24 hours of jack ruby who was a
nightclub operator in dallas shooting uh
you know oswald on
national television and stunning the
country including myself as a kid my
brother i think
all of us were watching
i thought it was a crime movie
within 24 hours of that bobby kennedy
has learned about jack ruby's
connections to the mob i have memos that
actually justice department memos
showing that bobby was on it immediately
and bobby later tells his press
secretary frank mankowitz when i looked
at the phone calls ruby was making
before dallas it looked like my witness
list for the rackets committee the
senate rackets committee where bobby was
chief counsel in the 50s
so i think dorothy kilogallon was on to
something uh then the question of course
is why did she die suddenly and
strangely that night
there's many many deaths like this in
the kennedy story i i mentioned two or
three of them because i think they're
particularly interesting i don't know
for certain what happened to her that
night she was a drinker uh she was known
to take pills uh
but
there were a number of anomalies as you
know about the crime scene that night
and they certainly raised questions
was this
the night of her interview with jack
ruby or no it was some time later she
was working on a story that she was
actually going to include in the book
and the one of the other strange things
about it is the manuscript that she was
working on was never found
salon has it though and is about is
going to publish it i heard
any other questions i think i've
answered everything huh no
ted kennedy what has he
done in this case ah good question
well i've been asked that question every
place i've gone on this book tour
i think
the heart of the kennedy family
at least when it came to investigating
these crimes really died with bobby
bobby was the last kennedy
who had the investigative zeal the fire
in the belly to get to the bottom of
this crime
uh
teddy i interviewed ted for the book
they made it very plain to me his
pressed people that he wouldn't talk
about the assassination the interview
would be over if i brought it up
they said that you know often of course
family tragedies
the the pain eases over time
but they told me with teddy it's
actually more painful today in some ways
his memories of his two brothers
so i i didn't talk to him about it i
know the kids bobby's kids who i
interviewed his grown children bobby jr
and joe kennedy kathleen i interviewed
them about it and they all said kathleen
was very eloquent about she said you
have to understand
how we were raised we were raised to
look forward not backward and somehow we
would i think emotionally collapse if
you were to look backward
well that kind of i can understand that
as a survival mechanism but it carries
its own emotional baggage
i
the truth is i don't think it is up to
the kennedy family to get to the bottom
of this it was a crime against uh
american democracy i think the
assassinations it's up to the judicial
system the political system and the
media all of which have failed miserably
to shed much light on this um
the kennedys you know i think have gone
through enough
do you have any idea what role linda
johnson may have played in this
situation he really stood to prophet
well exactly and he knew that he knew
that people would suspect him
immediately because it happened in texas
and he he
everyone knew how ambitious ruthlessly
ambitious uh he was
i don't believe that johnson had prior
knowledge or was involved in in the
conspiracy
and in fact he himself was stunned i
think and terrified that afternoon
i tell the story of how
they were before air force one took off
from love field in dallas they were
looking for the new president and god
free mccue who was the air force attache
in the white house
was you know looking all over and they
finally opened a bathroom door and he
was crouched in the bathroom muttering
conspiracy conspiracy they're going to
kill us all
later bill moyers who is his young aide
came up to him
while the
the plane was flying back to washington
and
lbj is looking pensively out of the
window and he says mr president what are
you thinking about he goes i'm wondering
when the missiles are going to start to
fly
and jamie galbraith who's i think a very
astute political historian the son of
john kenneth galbraith and he happens to
be
a professor in texas he told me his
interpretation of that was that he
thought the tensions that everyone knew
uh were boiling within the kennedy
administration had exploded and johnson
thought the military had taken over and
they were about to launch a nuclear war
a preemptive strike on the soviet union
so i think johnson was genuinely
terrified i could go on but i mean one
great tragedy about this of course is
that bobby and he both suspected a
conspiracy but because of their mutual
poisonous uh hatred for one another they
weren't able to put that aside
and i think uh work together to solve
the crime
died of a galloping cancer
while trying to talk or trying to still
talk to governor warren who refused to
meet with him that's right he wanted to
be taken out of the dallas jail because
he he knew what happened i think in
dallas jails
taken back to washington so he could
testify
openly about what he thought had
happened
and they refused to do that
i know there's speculation about whether
the cancer was induced or that sort of
thing i just don't know enough to
comment on that
back here
this is a question about there can be
heroism and a revisionism
issue
i'm completely agnostic on it i just
thought i'd push you on one
point it was made i don't remember if it
was in the times or in the chronicle
review but someone saw i've excited the
same speech you cited that was very
progressive and forward-looking but then
said but then a week later he delivered
a hawkish speech
and it wrote this as if it was a
reputation of your thesis all right just
curious what your response is
no
my remarks today and those reviews i
think simplify the portrait i try to
give of the kennedy presidency because
yes jfk was very much a man of his times
he did not want to be adelie stevenson
or john kerry or any of the democrats
who get rolled in uh presidential races
by hawkish republicans and he actually
outfoxed nixon in the 1960 election by
running as more of a hawk uh the famous
missile gap and and and he you know uh
he said he vowed to liberate cuba during
that uh presidential campaign
so he's very much a man of his times um
you know in his inaugural speech you see
again both of these themes
he says you know only if we have enough
arms will we be powerful enough not to
use them and of course he did uh set off
a major uh escalation in the defense
budget and the building of a enormous
nuclear arsenal
so jack kennedy is a complex guy and
he's fascinating to me because what he's
doing i think on the one hand
is uh through this use of hawkish
rhetoric and through some of his
policies
keeping his political opponents at bay
uh they're never able to do what they
you know did to clinton and say dukakis
and and in every democratic leader
virtually you can think of
because he did come off as muscular on
foreign policy and so on he'd been a
world war ii hero and that was very
important to him to have that posture
but the proof is in the pudding i think
when you look at what kennedy did
again and again when the chips were down
when they're trying to get him to go to
war
in vietnam to escalate there seriously
or cuba or nuclear war over berlin i
mean that's what he was being
pushed to do
jack kennedy slipped the knots of war
he was a very artful dancer and that's
his great beauty i think
and i think that provoked enormous rage
uh on the part of these hard-liners
within the national security
establishment
because they weren't able to best him
he bested them again and again so it's a
complex story and i think those
reviewers didn't capture
that
uh
that sense of him
yes
one of your goals is to get this opened
up again
can you envision
a person or a process that would be
strong enough or influential enough to
get behind this as opposed to
you know journalism and books and well
here's the only like that here's the
thing the one thing that makes me
hopeful about the times we're in now the
last time the system cracked open where
we really did have a lot of new
information not just about the
assassinations but
about other you know abuses on the part
of the cia and the fbi was of course in
the 1970s after the vietnam war and
after watergate and i think those crises
created such uh
pressure and and and cracks in the
system
that the system itself was forced in
some way to investigate itself
uh you also had a democratic presidency
with carter uh
in power coming in saying that he wanted
to open
you know the doors to these secrets and
so on
and you had two i think very aggressive
committees looking into this
i see some parallels today we have this
war in iraq this terribly unpopular war
that really has produced i think great
kind of chaos within the political
system in a way because the you know the
bush presidency is so isolated uh in in
its its reckless pursuit of this war
i think against the rest of the
political establishments will at this
point
and so if you now on top of that get a
democratic presidency particularly
progressive one maybe someone like
barack obama or even hillary clinton
although you know democrats sometimes
are loathed to open those doors too they
have to have a lot of pressure on them
to do it at the same time so that's the
third element of this there has to be i
think
something of
a catalyst here and it has to come from
the american people
and i'm not sure what that will be you
know oliver stone's film as i said
earlier is one of them
but books don't seem to have the same
impact as movies
i'm sorry back
this is sort of a post kennedy question
but i'm wondering if you what your
thoughts are on why subsequent democrats
have been
unable to replicate that outfoxing of
the hawks
well it's a good question i mean i you
know i think jfk was uh extraordinary uh
leader uh and so far we haven't been
blessed with that the same kind of
combination i think um
you know sort of a poetic vision
you know connected to uh sort of a hard
hardened toughened boston paul you know
and raised by a father i think in the
ways of power very shrewdly you know
whatever you think of joe kennedy an old
corrupt you know
uh
patriarch
he you know schooled his boy as well in
the way it's of power
and you know
clinton was a shrewd politician but i
don't see the same ability that that jfk
had to stand up to the hardliners the
way that kennedy did
again you know my concern with a cl
hillary or a barack is will they have
the same kind of backbone because you
know it seems like hillary at this point
is so
um concerned with establishing her bona
fides when it comes to you know her
military expertise and so forth
you know jack kennedy after the bay of
pigs was willing to say screw you to
these guys
you know schlesinger arthur schlesinger
told me he had complete contempt for the
his own joint chiefs of staff
he thought that they were empty suits
and
i just don't see that same kind of will
power yet among the democratic field
today
yes
that seems to have surfaced
that's a big question and i think i got
criticized for that too in one of those
reviews um well howard hunt of course
was a legendary cia guy part of the
secret warren castro very ardent
anti-communist another kennedy hater
hung out with a number of these people
who were later associated uh
yeah you know uh to doubt with dallas
and hunt and then of course becomes
famous for his role as the uh the head
of the watergate burglary team
well um
hunt didn't talk
you know didn't talk didn't talk people
wanted him to talk about what he knew uh
in his retirement
uh
he's a cagey guy a disinformation
specialist
a novelist a fabulous you know so
you know you have to take things he says
with the grain of salt of course but
interestingly what he does at the end of
his life under uh and with under the
encouragement or prodding of his oldest
son saint john hunt is to begin to sort
of unravel some of these secrets
and i think his book is here american
spy he does it partly there but that
process was aborted when his second wife
laura hunt freaked out because she
thought he was telling too much and his
lawyer and they stepped in at that point
and so what his book does is something
very odd it does it oj what it does is
uh sort of says if the cia was involved
in the assassination the president this
is how they might have done it
and he stopped short of going all the
way but
what he did with his son
with notes that i've seen handwritten
notes and an audio tape and a videotape
is to go further and what he says there
is really mind-blowing because what he
says is in 1963 i was invited to a
meeting at a cia safe house in miami
where the plot to kill the president was
discussed and i was asked to join the
plot i declined because one of the other
cia officials i didn't trust he was an
alcoholic which he was named william
harvey and so i played a sidelines role
i was a bench warmer well that's
remarkable too
and you know rolling stone was the only
publication really to jump on that and
give it the kind of i think attention it
deserved i know 60 minutes was looking
into it
well now people are just dismissing the
messenger saying you can't trust hunt
you know he made things up but the fact
is he didn't make stuff up about the
assassination well he did what he said
was all along the soviet union or castro
was behind it so why at the end of his
life would he suddenly incriminate his
agency and himself it's curious i mean i
i don't know entirely what to make of it
but i think it deserves more attention
than it's gotten from the media
yes what david what would you point to
as the best piece of evidence that
oswald was not the lone shooter
was not wife the lone shooter
where to begin
well i mean
just to name a recent one there's a new
study uh of the bullet fragments from
the crime scene dealy plaza fbi uh
metallurgist who said that based on his
study of those fragments they must have
come from two different guns
but i mean you know
for me
i'm not a forensics expert in what
happened in dealey plaza i didn't want
to go down that was a rabbit hole i
didn't want to go down for me what was
convincing to me i just have to say was
talking to people who had been there or
who talked to people uh
you know like kenny o'donnell's son who
said this is what my dad told me it was
the eyewitness testimony people were in
the motorcade that day and my chapter on
dallas i try to create a sense of what
it felt like to be in those cars because
they felt like hunted animals and they
felt like the gunfire was coming from
multiple directions and they were caught
in a crossfire that's what it felt like
and they weren't just hysterical people
who had no sense of guns or what they
sounded like these were world war ii
veterans
um and so to me it's hearing from these
people exactly what it felt like or
reading their testimony abraham zapruder
this wonderful man this
uh russian immigrant this dress
manufacturer who's very patriotic guy
standing there with his you know home
movie camera taking his pictures and
capturing these horrible moments and
then later screaming they've killed him
they killed him they sho they shot him
down like a dog
jackie kennedy saying they killed him
i'm not taking my gore drenched chanel
suit off their famous pink suit because
i want them to see what they have done
to my husband that was what they felt
like that's what you know now you could
say well it in the you know the the
trauma of a crime many people say
different things but there was just so
much
evidence like this eyewitness testimony
you can see pictures today people
pointing up at the grassy knoll
motorcycle cops running up the hill
i think clearly someone was firing from
the book depository but clearly fire was
coming from some other
place as well
know you opened with a comment on the uh
uh forgotten the author's name but the
1600 page book
which uh yes supposedly goes through
everything have you i'm just curious
have you read that book and what is your
thoughts on
all the points he makes and all the
details that he goes through to refute
that right no it was a joke because i
haven't had the time to read yet but i
have read the introduction i've read the
parts that relate to my book about bobby
kennedy and those parts don't inspire
confidence because what bullios he does
is something very superficial he accepts
what bobby kennedy was saying in public
and this is an interesting story and
this is a big part of my book because
what bobby kennedy decided to do was to
accept the warren report publicly
because i think he felt if he were to
reject the war and report publicly all
hell would break loose in the media
there'd be a firestorm and he wasn't
prepared to publicly uh open this case
or because he knew he didn't have the
power
the very day uh
that he learns his brother's killed his
power begins to evaporate as attorney
general i begin the book with the kind
of chilly phone calls he gets from j
edgar hoover his arch nemesis the head
of the fbi who tells him with almost a
sense of pleasure bobby says that his
brother has been killed
he knows that the fbi is not going to
follow his directions after that and
they're in charge of the investigation
lbj again the new president hates
bobby's guts and vice versa
so his power is fleeting and in true
kennedy fashion what he's doing is going
underground
and doing it himself and going to
trusted aids you know he slipped back
into the justice department after he was
uh in the senate to look secretly at
files with walt sheridan this former fbi
man who was his right-hand investigator
he tracked leads to mexico city in new
orleans when garrison was reopening the
case he was doing this very privately
but anybody
who knows anything about bobby in fact
it's in the two standard biographies by
arthur schlesinger and evan thomas of
robert kennedy that bobby kennedy
privately dismissed the warren report as
nothing more than a pr exercise
aimed at lulling the american people to
sleep
well buliosi certainly has read those
books
and so for him to just
blandly accept what bobby was saying
strategically in public as the truth
about what bobby kennedy really thought
happened in dallas is ridiculous so that
doesn't inspire confidence
and uh how the bullets hit him and the
problem they had about i'm sorry
what about kindly yes
well conley also thought that
there was uh
shots from a second guy he thought he
was hit by not by the same the magic
bullet uh and so that was his feeling
too he he tried to blur it later and say
uh you know
that oswald was the lone gunman but it
was a different bullet which
is inconsistent of course so
uh but yes he also and he and his wife
nelly had the uh you know their
testimony went against the official
story
what role would nixon have played do you
have any idea he was in dallas that day
yes and again there's a lot of rumors
about nixon was he uh in on it somehow i
don't think so but nixon thought there
was a conspiracy uh there's a
fascinating
passage in bob haldeman's memoir in
which uh when nixon's you know in
trouble uh watergate has started to uh
you know
uh creep closer to the white house in
desperation he tries to get the cia to
get him out of uh this fix he's in and
richard helms is head of the cia at the
time a very serpentine character as
you'll see in my book and he sends bob
haldeman with this mysterious message
to
helms and he brings helms into his
office hold him and says you know the
president says if you know uh this
watergate thing gets out of hand that
the whole bay of pigs thing could be
blown the whole bay of pigs uh thing
could be exposed and of course the bay
of pigs this is like you know uh 10
years before
and you know helms who's normally very
composed and crafty character jumps up
and says you know we had nothing to do
with the bay of pigs
well of course the cia had everything to
do with the bay of pigs and that's a
historical fact and and he wasn't
denying that
and so haldeman is puzzled about this
and he later talks to ehrlichman his
sidekick and they figure out that the
bay of pigs is nixon's code for the jfk
assassination for dallas and so
basically what nixon is doing is trying
to blackmail the cia and says i know i
know about you and cuba that whole
operation and how it backfired against
kennedy and got him killed and i'm going
to you know threaten to expose you
unless you help bail me out here so i
think that was a very interesting uh
revealing
incident
yes over here
would you mind mentioning who you think
are the more
intelligent uh assassination
investigators that you mentioned earlier
yeah sure
i'm they're acknowledged in my book
because a number of them were very
helpful and generous and they didn't
have to be because you know sometimes
people are more proprietary about these
things but anthony summers someone i
mentioned earlier i thought tony summers
who's an irish uh journalist
uh
you know did i think one of the best
early books on this it was called
conspiracy and then the title was later
changed to not not not in your lifetime
uh or our lifetime
and
again jeff morley who's
just completed the book uh it'll be
coming out next year this washington
post reporter i mentioned
peter dale scott who's a great
[Music]
scholar over in berkeley who's been at
this for years his book deep politics
was very
i think interesting
um
there was a book on the zapruder film by
a wisconsin historian named david rohn
that's also very good that came out two
or three years ago um
we can talk more about if you're
interested in having a bibliography i'd
be happy to
to help you out with that but um but
there are a number of them they're quite
good
yeah actually one thing
that as brothers and haven't gotten to
the same school and growing up in los
angeles for those old enough to remember
when it comes to this issue of was
kennedy a cold warrior was he a liberal
how did he stand people forget how
conservative and how right wing
so much of the country was in the 60s
and going back to our school i remember
when kennedy was killed there were and
there was a school where a lot of the
power elite from
california came reagan's kitchen cabinet
nixon's advisors and so forth
were thrilled that kennedy had been
there were cheers i remember in my
classroom it was announced that he was
killed yeah
no exactly in southern california was a
bastion of uh
john bircher you know activity in fact
kennedy twice in his life decided to go
into the heart
sort of the the the belly of the beast
and and confront that uh sentiment uh
the sentiment said any negotiation is
treason
uh which is what they felt and one
occasion was in los angeles where he
delivered a famous address at the
hollywood palladium and there were
thousands of demonstrators out in front
right wing demonstrators uh calling him
a traitor and the second time of course
was dallas
and you know another amazing speech to
read besides his famous piece speech
which i quoted from earlier at american
university was the speech that kennedy
would have delivered at the dallas trade
mart
if he had lived
and what he essentially says is you know
we we must get over this sense as a
country that negotiation that peace is
weakness
and um
and again it's just a very radical
notion at that time it is today every
camp every you know you look at the
republicans they're all trying to
out uh do each other when it comes to
rattling sabres and their debates and
the democrats you know to some extent
are too i mean even barack obama saying
you know iran won't be off the table and
all of that well that's rhetoric
you know that maybe they have to use in
a campaign as i said jfk did it earlier
but the question is will we get some
kind of visionary leadership
at some point if a democrat is elected
someone who's willing to say you know
let's rethink america's role in the
world do we have to be uh
does america have to
rule through intimidation
you know
again and again kennedy would say things
like we are just one country in this
world and another beautiful speech he
made that i quote in my book we're just
one country uh we have to learn to live
in a in a multi-polar world
where we don't dominate everything
and i mean you know
his rhetoric is just so um
what's the word is so relevant for for
today's world and again i hope that is
conveyed in the book
but yes i mean he was up against
enormously reactionary forces i don't
think he would have necessarily
had an easy time defeating goldwater in
64. that's another reason he had to go
to texas he knew he had lost the whole
south when i read these books they drive
me crazy there's a book by a british
historian saying that kennedy's were you
know
remiss on civil rights and they didn't
care about civil rights well yes they
were slow on civil rights that's clear
they were very afraid of splitting the
democratic party of losing the
democratic south and they did finally do
the right thing and that's what happened
they split the democratic party
something we still see today that
started with jack kennedy because he
finally stood up and he did the right
thing on civil rights
and so he had to go to texas because
that was along with florida probably the
only states in the deep south he could
have won
so the country uh you know we all think
of him as this charming charismatic
prince who would have had an easy time
being reelected in 64. but the truth is
he he probably would have had a tough
tough campaign
have you ever come across
reinhard galen
and uh the fact that spas raikkonen met
oswald when he came back from the soviet
union
and helped oswald get back to texas and
spas reagan was a nazi collaborator from
the ukraine originally and why he would
help oswald get back to dallas
is is a mystery to me
and it's also mr me why the cia hired
reinhard galen who was hitler's top
intel official on his eastern front in
the soviet union right now you're down a
tunnel that i i wasn't able to go down
but yeah i mean the the major point
you're making is very interesting one
which is you know oswald defected to the
soviet union and then came back with
with surprising ease
senator richard schweiker from
pennsylvania who on the church committee
looked into the
kennedy assassination said made a very
famous statement at the time saying the
fingerprints of intelligence are all
over lee harvey oswald and i i believe
that's true
maybe
one more and then we'll call it a day an
evening
any others
well thank you very much for your
patience
david talbott's new book brothers the
hidden history of the kennedy years the
author is founder and former
editor-in-chief of the online magazine
salon david talbott